rafael nadal calienta antes del abierto
de australia en el que podría romper un
récord el español cuenta actualmente con
20 títulos de gran slam junto a dos
hombres roger federer que no estarán
australia debido a una lesión y nova
djokovic que actualmente domina los
titulares en todo el mundo al abordar la
situación nadal quiso destacar que
ningún jugador es más importante que el
propio tenis
pero no hay ningún jugador en la
historia que sea más importante que un
evento no los jugadores se quieran y
luego se van y vienen otros jugadores
ustedes andy en el abierto de usted le
será un gran abierto de australia con o
sin él es ese es mi punto de vista de mi
playa si djokovic logra por segunda vez
evitar su deportación podría enfrentarse
a nadal en un choque de semifinales
el número 3 del mundo alexis pérez ha
defendido a djokovic
entiendo la perspectiva del pueblo
australiano del gobierno australiano
pero el gobierno australiano y el
gobierno de victoria deberían haber
tenido claro lo que va a pasar de
antemano creo que no es muy justo que
una persona venga aquí y no pueda jugar
el tres veces ganador de un grand slam
andy murray ha dicho que no han salido
ganadores en esta situación
extraordinaria si solo uno obviamente
que se resuelva creo que sería bueno
para todo si así fuera parece que se ha
alargado durante mucho tiempo y si no es
bueno para el tenis no es bueno para el
abierto de australia no es bueno para
nova mira mis sensaciones que animaría a
la gente a vacunarse pero si siento que
la gente debería ser capaz de tomar sus
propias decisiones
de donde station con el futuro de
djokovic todavía incierto la espera para
romper el récord del vigésimo primer
slam parece que se prolongará al menos
un poco más